for a second present for the second day
of Christmas we have two blankets they
are similar in some ways I got one in
July and the other one in December so
let's have a look at the first one it's
quite big and you can see I'm not good
at making beds you can see it's a
present from the American Chemical
Society I gave a lecture in July to the
annual general meeting of the Royal
Society of Chemistry they thought I'd
make it a bit more exciting the
president of the American Chemical
Society was there and a few weeks later
this came through the post with a note
saying that the president had loved my
lecture and he was a present it really
is a blanket and it's pretty up-to-date
got fluoro viim and livermorium you can
wear it if you want like a cloak that's
the first one let's lay it on the bench
the second one is quite similar it is
also a blanket but it's actually what in
American is called a quilt and in
England is called an eiderdown this is
what you put on the top of your bed my
arms aren't quite long enough and this
has been stitched by a special stitching
machine it looks as if it's handmade but
in fact it's quite a cunning piece of
computer programming this was given to
me by Theo gray who is famous for his
periodic tables he has a machine I'm not
quite sure what it's for
but one of the things it can do is to
produce these quilts I had huge problems
bringing this back on the train from
London where I was given it eventually I
wrapped it up in the plastic sheet with
the luggage strap round it and I met a
fan on the train but I didn't have the
courage to
and wrap it I think that these are both
really nice I haven't got the slightest
idea what to do with them because I
don't really want to have them on my bed
well I would like to but I'm not sure
other members of my family would be
quite so keen but I think in the end
we'll hang them up here in the School of
Chemistry at Nottingham on the second
day of Christmas we have two periodic
table blankets on the first day of
Christmas we had some tartaric acid from
a wine barrel now let's see what we're
going to have on day three
patriotic pretend place where people
post photoshopped images of for example
Abe Lincoln holding the US Constitution
while riding a bear on the moon and
shooting space Nazis yeah it'll just say
America across the top with a big
exclamation marks it is in a kind of
making fun of a particular sort of hyper
patriotism